- Okay, I was expecting
to roast all these drinks
and be like like a snob, but like,
I haven't had a bad drink yet.
(soft hip hop music)
Hi, what's up?
My name is Chris and I worked
as a barista at Voltaire in San Jose.
And people always ask baristas,
"have you ever served a celebrity?"
I haven't, but I see a lot
of people leaking celebrity orders online
and I thought I'd try to make some
of them at home and see
if there are any good.
I know Ariana Grande's
had that one coffee line
in that one song that was
everywhere last year.
♪ I've been drinking coffee ♪
Apparently now she's like
a Starbucks ambassador
and she has her own secret menu drink
called the Ariana Grande Frappuccino.
Doesn't make that much sense
because she's vegan, but
it does sound really good.
It's gonna start off with
a vanilla bean Frappuccino
which apparently doesn't
have coffee in it.
So I'm gonna use vanilla bean ice cream
with milk and ice.
And I'm gonna add in raspberry syrup.
I couldn't find that syrup anywhere.
So I just use raspberry preserves
and turned it into a syrup
on the stove by adding water
and a little bit more sugar.
I'm surprised the raspberry jam
into syrup thing turned
out as well as it did.
Then we got chocolate
chips, chocolate syrup
and I'm gonna mix that
in and blend it all.
And obviously you've got to
serve it in a clear glass,
top it with whipped cream
and a little bit of caramel.
Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. That's that's really good
but I don't know what else I was expecting
because it was literally
just an icy milkshake
which is always gonna be good.
So it definitely would have been better
if I used full fat ice cream and milk.
That's probably where the raspberry comes
into play because it's a little bit acidic
and acid generally tends
to cut through fats.
That's why people use like
lemon juice, vinegar, lime,
whenever they make like
really fatty meats.
This is coming out of nowhere, but I feel
like a pinch of salt, you
know, like salted caramel.
I don't know why ,that
would make it better.
Now, Charli D'Amelio
recently did a partnership
with Dunkin on a drink called The Charli.
I'm gonna taste test this recipe using
the actual Dunkin cold-brew packets.
And I'm just gonna follow the
instructions that they give
on the box.
I'm gonna measure out all
of my water just to make
sure I'm not messing this up.
I think four cups is
like 950 milliliters
or something like that.
And I'm gonna Saran Wrap the top
of my container and put it
in the fridge overnight.
It's been about 12 hours
and I took the cold brew
out and made The Charli right over here.
It's just cold brew with milk and caramel.
I have no clue what a caramel pump is.
So I just went with three tablespoons.
It's supposed to be three pumps.
So I'm gonna taste test the pure cold brew
on its own just
because I don't want to
do Dunkin dirty like that.
I don't want to mess
up the recipe and then like, not like it.
Okay. I kind of messed up
because I got donuts last night.
So my mouth is already
really clammy and sticky.
So the caramel definitely
doesn't help that much.
Okay. So a few things to note.
One, as expected,
it is a super dark, really low
acidity kind of bitter roast.
And that makes a lot of
sense, 'cause they probably
expect people to drink it
with milk and this kind
of a coffee bean pulls itself
up to milk really well.
And it has a really
light body in the sense
that the mouth feel in
your mouth feels physically
like water, but it is super strong.
I know the whole flavor notes
thing is super pretentious
but I'm not getting
anything specific in here.
Maybe chocolaty, nutty kind
of stuff, no fruitiness
or tartness or bright
sweetness in the coffee itself.
And that makes a lot of sense
because they're probably trying
to appeal to as many people
as possible by using a
really balanced blend.
And it tastes exactly
like you would expect
traditional coffee to taste.
Like I used to think
that I would never ever drink coffee black
but that's just because I
was using really dark roasts
from large commercial brands.
They really try to sell you on that saying
that it's stronger, but you
can get a stronger flavor
in lighter or medium roast just
by the way that you brew it.
And dark roast tend to hide
inconsistencies and
imperfections in beans.
But yeah, I really like this.
Back to Ariana Grande, she
partnered with Starbucks
on another drink called
the Cloud Macchiato.
It looks cool because it
has this really fluffy foam
that they call Cloud Foam.
And I think we can replicate
that by using icing sugar
and powdered egg whites
which I got in the form
of meringue powder.
I got some of the Starbucks espresso beans
but I don't have an espresso machine.
So I try to make something
that's just close enough
by dialing it in
on a Moka pot and know it's
technically not espresso.
Like it doesn't have enough pressure.
So you don't end up
with that crema on top, but like, come on.
I tasted it before putting the milk
and and it's close enough, like, relax.
I'll take it off the stove
once it starts bubbling and I'll run it
under cold water to stop the extraction.
It should give me about
45 to 50 grams or so.
And then I gotta make the foam.
I don't have an electric mixer,
so we're gonna have to
whip this one by hand
which gives me really bad
flashbacks to Dalgona Coffee.
So I brought an elbow brace
just in case of tendonitis.
Yeah, whipping anything by hand takes
about like 20 years or so.
It's about the journey
not the destination or
something like that.
Put some milk and then get a spoon,
and make it look on nice.
Look at that.
And then they make this
waffle thing with the caramel.
Here we have it right here.
All of the normal size cups
were in the dishwasher,
but this is actually closer
to the traditional macchiato size.
The Italian macchiato is just two shots
of espresso with a tiny little
dollop of foam milk on top.
This is not the Starbucks macchiato
because they do it like backwards.
There's just like a latte macchiato
but the typical cafe macchiato
or espresso macchiato
is like barely any milk.
And it's like that small.
So let's go ahead and try it.
Okay, I was expecting to roast all
of these drinks and be
like, like a snob, but like
I haven't had a bad drink yet
but the caramel on top is
actually is a caramel or caramel?
The caramel, caramel. The
caramel's a nice touch.
I feel like all Starbucks drinks
are kind of the same thing.
It's just like vaguely milky coffee kind
of flavor with some hint of sweetness.
Yeah. The foam barely
tastes like anything.
So I tried to find other
interesting coffee orders.
Everyone else just gets soy lattes.
But in an interview,
Chloe Kardashians said
that she gets a venti seven
pump, no water chai latte.
First of all, chai is just
tea, so it has to have water.
Second, how is it a pump?
What I think they mean is
that they just brew chai
tea and then reduce it
down to like a concentrate
that they use as a syrup.
And then when they serve
it, they just cut it
with water to make it back into
tea and then make the latte.
So Chloe probably just wants
the concentrate with the milk.
I saw that Starbucks on
their website shows what's
in their chai and I could
do that from scratch,
but it's kind of similar
to this teabag that I
found at the grocery store.
I'm gonna use seven bags
and then reduce it down
into a syrup with sugar
that's roughly what seven pumps would be
in volume and then make
the latte out of that.
Let's go ahead and try it.
(soft hip hop music)
Okay. That's not bad.
If I had to pick a least favorite one
it would probably be this one
but I'm surprised that it's pretty spicy
and it cuts through the milk pretty well.
I learned a few things.
One, you can make a
dessert taste fancier just
by adding some kind of acidic tart fruit.
Even if the dessert itself isn't supposed
to be acidic or tart.
I learned that cold-brew packets work.
You can just make syrups
on the stove and foam is exhausting.
(upbeat hip hop music)